ALEX KOMOROSKE: Hi.
Welcome.
So we're going to get
started before we're
all full in this room
just for the live stream.
I'm Alex Komoroske.
I'm lead product manager on
Chrome's web platform team.
ELISABETH MORANT: And hi.
My name is Elisabeth Morant
and I am the product manager
for Chrome security.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
today, we're going
to tell you about four forces,
some of them old, some of them
new, that together
combine to create
the next generation mobile web.
Now, a lot of times
at I/O, we tell you
about all kinds of
amazing features
that are going to come six
months, maybe a year from now,
but today, we're going to cover
only things that are already
shipped in Chrome
that you can use.
So we don't have that much
time, so we'll cover things
at a pretty high
level, but there's
lots of great
DevBytes and Box Talks
here at I/O that go into
more depth on all of these.
So let's get started.
So the reason that
Elisabeth and I are here
is because we love Chrome.
ELISABETH MORANT:
And we love Chrome
because, like many of
you, we love the web.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I mean,
it's kind of amazing
that you can connect with any
topic or community you want
without asking
anyone permission,
which allows all kinds
of wacky stuff to happen.
So my personal
favorite is this site
called Real Ultimate Power.
Anybody know what that is?
So there's a few
of you out there.
So this is this
amazing satire site.
This guy has a
page about ninjas.
He's super crazy into
ninjas and he hates pirates.
ELISABETH MORANT: Oh, of course.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
That's important.
But he just put
this site up there.
People thought it was hilarious.
They shared it.
People found it and loved it.
My crew team, we
actually found it
and loved it so much
that we actually posed
for a picture as ninjas and
uploaded it to the site.
ELISABETH MORANT: OK.
You have to show
everyone this photo.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
I'm trying to psych
myself up for that,
but here's the picture
that I am extremely
proud of from a
number of years ago.
ELISABETH MORANT:
Which one is you?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So I'm
actually not entirely sure,
but based on the
farmer's tan, I'm
pretty sure that that one's me.
Anyway, I embarrassed myself,
you embarrass yourself.
ELISABETH MORANT: OK.
All right.
I guess it's only fair.
So when I was 12, I was really
into video games, especially
adventure games, so I
took to the internet
to make my first website.
And clearly, this was my first
introduction to programming
and I owned up to it with
the giant space in the bottom
that I didn't know
how to get rid of.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Very subtle.
ELISABETH MORANT:
But the point is
that this let me connect with
this huge community of people
out there who had the
same passions as I did.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah,
all 400 of them,
if I see that counter right.
ELISABETH MORANT: Half of them
were me refreshing the page.
Anyway, so these are just
a few weird examples,
but the web is a really
powerful technology
that's enabled a number of very
thriving businesses to form.
E-commerce alone in 2014 was
worth more than $1.5 trillion.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Jeez.
ELISABETH MORANT: That's huge.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's
trillion with a T.
ELISABETH MORANT: Yes.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wow.
So the point of this is
we've shared some examples
from our past, but
we're not alone.
In fact, I bet that almost
everyone in this room
and on the live stream has
a connection to the web.
It's this amazing, vibrant,
weird, global community
that we're all a part of.
It's awesome.
ELISABETH MORANT: OK.
So the title of the talk is the
next generation mobile web, so
what are we doing on mobile?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's
a great question.
So mobile was a
fundamental shift.
It changed the
assumptions from desktop.
So performance became
incredibly important,
making sure that you could
hit 60 frames per second
on devices that were
running battery power.
And there's other
capabilities that
just became totally critical.
Push notifications,
for example, are
just crucial to how you
interact with your mobile device
and the web couldn't do it.
To be honest, native
apps really just
were well suited to
this environment.
ELISABETH MORANT: All right.
So I guess we should all
just make native apps, then?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I'm
not saying that.
Now, native apps are great,
but the web is also amazing.
In fact, a number
of its strengths
that made it so strong on
desktop are as strong as ever.
So just the other
day I looked, and I
checked to see how many people
used DevTools in the past week.
So as a point of
comparison, Android
is an amazingly
successful platform.
I've seen public stats
somewhere around four million
or so for an estimate
for developers.
So how many people do you
think loaded Chrome DevTools
in the past week?
ELISABETH MORANT: A week?
Maybe a million.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
Turns out the answer
is 25 million people
have used Chrome
DevTools in the last week.
That's really cool because
that's not a stagnant number.
That's actually
growing over time.
So the point is not
all these people
are building huge,
complicated websites.
Some of them are tinkering.
But this community that we're
all a part of, it's huge, it's
strong, and it's growing.
So this talk today
is for those people
in this community, those
25 million people who
love the web.
[APPLAUSE]
ELISABETH MORANT:
So to start, we're
going to talk about reach,
the superpower of the web.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We're also then
talk about performance and how
we made big strides there.
ELISABETH MORANT:
And finally, we're
going to talk about
engagement, how we're
helping you build
immersive experience that
keep users coming back.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So the three
of these separately, whatever.
But together, combined
with that global community,
that's something special.
ELISABETH MORANT: So the
web is extremely successful,
largely because of
its reach, and we
don't give it enough credit.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I mean, we
give it a fair bit of credit.
We understand that browsers
are on every device
and every operating system.
ELISABETH MORANT: That's true.
Even now cars have browsers and
we have over one billion Chrome
users, and that
doesn't even count
other browsers and other
people browsing the web.
But what I'm talking
about is another aspect
of reach, that is, not
the reach of browsers
but the reach of content.
So the way I think
about it is the web
is a series of trees
with nodes, right,
where every website is
a tree and the root is
like Pinterest.com,
and then you dig deep,
and then you're on a
board and that's a leaf.
And then if you jump
from URL to URL,
then you're jumping from
leaf node to leaf node
and so on and so
forth, and that's
why it's so easy jump
between link to link.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I
have literally no idea
what you're talking about.
ELISABETH MORANT: OK.
Fair.
Let me show you an example.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Great.
ELISABETH MORANT: So if I
could jump to the demo laptop?
Great.
So let's start on a video of the
latest Imagine Dragons single,
"Shots."
So I know that every single
one of you in the audience
loves Imagine Dragons
probably not as much as I do.
It's basically the best
band that's ever existed.
It's better than
the Beatles, really.
I could go on about it.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wow.
OK.
Sure.
ELISABETH MORANT: So the point
is the web, reach, trees,
right.
So YouTube is a tree and
this particular piece
of video content is a node.
And so I could just
share a URL with you
and then you can watch
this piece of content.
And likewise, I can learn
more about Imagine Dragons,
navigate through YouTube,
maybe jump to Wikipedia.
At this point, I've
jumped from one node
to the node of another
tree, the Wikipedia tree,
and I so easily reached a piece
of content deep in Wikipedia
just by clicking a link.
And so from here, I
can read some articles,
jump around, learn
about Alt-J, jump back.
I'm not going to bring
you through the entirety
of the web.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That
would take a long time.
ELISABETH MORANT: And I can
jump to their band website.
In this case, I
wouldn't necessarily
want an app for every
band that I love,
but I do want to be able
to go to their website
and learn about things like
when they're going on tour
and find out-- hey, Alex?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: What?
ELISABETH MORANT: Can you
take over for a second?
I just-- they're
on tour and I know
the tickets are
going to sell out
and I just really need to
buy a ticket right now.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
Are you kidding me?
ELISABETH MORANT: Please?
You know the slides.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
ELISABETH MORANT: Actually,
can we jump to WolfVision
so everyone can share in this
experience of buying tickets
with me?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wow.
You really love Imagine Dragons.
ELISABETH MORANT: I
love Imagine Dragons.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
While she's doing
that, it's kind of cool
what she was doing.
In the course of
a few seconds, she
visited what, like seven
different services,
all without installing anything.
That's kind of cool.
It's something that just
happens that we totally
take for granted on the web.
ELISABETH MORANT: Anyway, sorry.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
So it turns out the
tickets aren't on sale yet,
so I just went to
their website and opted
to get a notification when
they come back on sale.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
ELISABETH MORANT:
Anyway, so where were we?
Can we go back to the slides?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Something
about reach, I think.
ELISABETH MORANT: Oh right.
Friction.
Friction sucks, friction
being the amount of overhead
from a user wanting to get
somewhere to actually being
able to get to that piece
of content, and on the web,
it's as easy as
just tapping a link.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
So I think I see
what's going on here
but this seems all
really abstract.
Is this something that
actually matters in practice?
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah.
So here's something.
On average, the average person
uses around 12 to 20 apps
per month on their phone.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Depending
on which stat you use.
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah,
depending on what source
you look at.
So keeping that in mind,
guess how many sites
the average Chrome for Android
user visits in every month.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
So are we including third party
content and iframes and stuff?
ELISABETH MORANT: No.
I'm talking about
direct link navigation,
going through the Omnibox.
This is all unique domains.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
So 12 to 20 for apps.
Maybe double that,
like 40 or so.
ELISABETH MORANT: Over
100 websites a month.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wow.
That's actually
really impressive.
I didn't realize it was
going to be that big.
ELISABETH MORANT: See?
That right there
is reach in action.
It's so easy for people
to just tap a link
and visit tons of new
sites with no friction.
And in fact, it turns out
that 85% of US retailers'
mobile traffic is on the
web, and that accounts
for 90% of their revenue.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wow.
ELISABETH MORANT: And now
this is just one example,
and this is why I consider
reach the superpower of the web.
So the way I think of it is--
bear with me-- you want people
to form a meaningful
relationship with your stuff,
but first people
have to find it.
So it's kind of like the web
is one big speed dating venue
where you can jump from person
to person and get to know them
a little bit, just like you can
jump from website to website
and get to know it a little
bit before committing
and developing a relationship
with that content.
And you're never afraid
to necessarily click
a link because what's the
worst that can happen?
After five minutes,
the bell rings and you
move onto the next place.
And the point is that then, when
you decide you want to commit,
you can build that
relationship over time.
And so we take reach for
granted but it's really
as important as ever.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So that's
reach, but of course,
just as important on
mobile is performance.
But what does good
performance mean?
How do you know when you're done
and when you're good enough?
ELISABETH MORANT:
Well, that's easy.
It's just the amount of time
it takes a page to load.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
So page load time
is something that we've all
known about as a community.
We call it PLT or whatever.
We have good understanding,
got good tools.
There's whole conferences on it.
That's not to say we're
perfect, by the way.
There's a lot of us
who don't necessarily
practice what we preach here.
But on mobile, other
metrics matter, too,
like scrolling performance.
To have the illusion that
the content is sticking
to your finger as
you scroll, you've
got to hit 60 frames
per second consistently.
But which of these
metrics should we
look at and which one
should we be optimizing?
So the answer to that is this
concept that we call RAIL.
ELISABETH MORANT:
Great, another acronym.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Of course.
What did you expect?
So it's basically a
conceptual framework
for knowing when you have
good enough performance.
So the key insight is when
is performance good enough?
Well, when the user
can't perceive it.
That's when it's good enough.
ELISABETH MORANT: I'm pretty
sure Don Draper didn't actually
say that.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Good catch.
He didn't say that,
as far as I know,
but he might have
said it if only
he had cared about
this kind of stuff.
But the point is
there's actually
a lot of research on this.
So if you're trying to get
that illusion of smooth motion,
of course you want to
hit 60 frames per second,
which means 16.67 milliseconds
to put each frame on screen.
Now, if you want to
have the user feel
that the thing happened
instantaneously,
research tells us you've
got about 100 milliseconds.
And if you do something
within one second, well then,
someone's train of
thought can stay on it,
and if you take more
than 10 seconds,
well then they're off playing
solitaire or something.
ELISABETH MORANT: Definitely
took more than 10 seconds.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Thank you
for that great example.
So anyway, these are the
golden standard for you to hit,
and RAIL is basically
just hitting
these goals in the context
of your web performance.
So the first one is
R for reaction time.
So basically, this
is exactly when
the user puts their
finger down on the glass
and starts interacting.
You have 100 milliseconds to do
something, to show you got it.
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah, sure.
Otherwise, the app
feels broken or slow.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Exactly.
So that's 100 milliseconds
to change the button color
or to show a loading
indicator or show, I got it.
I'm not frozen.
Next one is Animation time.
You've got, of course,
60 frames per second
is the gold standard, which
means 16.67 milliseconds.
Now, that's not a lot of
time, so if you do anything,
you might miss that, so you
have to really, really careful.
So the next one is Idle.
ELISABETH MORANT: Why
is Idle part of RAIL?
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
So you have to do
some work that's going to take
some time, like image decodes
or whatever, and you can't do
it when the user is interacting,
so a good time is when
the user doesn't have
their finger on the screen.
ELISABETH MORANT: Right.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: However, what
if the user's finger comes back
in while you're doing that work?
ELISABETH MORANT: I see.
You don't want to be
the middle of idle time
because otherwise, you're not
going to be able to react.
The user might think
the app is broken.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right.
So you want to make sure
you chunk up your work you
that you even in idle
so if at any point
the user starts interacting
with you, you're good to go
and can hit that 100
milliseconds, the R of RAIL.
And the last one, of course,
is our friend Load time.
Of course, it still matters,
if not more, on mobile.
And the gold standard
here to keep the train
of thought solid is one second.
ELISABETH MORANT: I wish
everything loaded that fast.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
It's pretty low, right?
Remember, this is for
perfect performance,
and things like Quick
and Service Worker
actually make this feasible
for the first time.
And of course, if you can't
get your entire site loaded up
on screen, well,
the next best thing
is putting reasonable pixels
on screen to show I've loaded,
I'm working, I'm not just stuck.
ELISABETH MORANT: Sure,
some loading image.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right.
ELISABETH MORANT: So this
is all great in theory,
but what does it actually
mean in practice?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So RAIL is
a great conceptual framework
for us across the community.
So for browser
vendors in particular,
it means giving
you as developers
more headroom, more
space for your own code
to do this work so that you
don't cross those boundaries.
So the Chrome Web
Platform team is
way over-- I think 200
engineers last time I checked.
A lot of people,
the vast majority,
work on some aspect
of performance.
We've been doing tons of
work, vast re-architectures,
to optimize for
mobile performance.
Now, we don't have time to dive
into any of these in any depth,
but let me just pick one.
So a couple months ago,
we launched this feature
called the Scheduler.
And the basic idea
is that when you
start interacting with a
page, that's when, of course,
you want to prioritize scrolling
and frames over everything
else.
And it turns out that this
can have a really big impact,
especially during
page load when there's
lots of work being done.
So here we've got a video,
and if you can roll the video,
we have on the left with
the scheduler, on the right
without.
We refresh the page so
we're doing tons of work,
and you can see the one
on the left scrolls way
more smoothly than
the one on the right.
So this is a great example of
RAIL motivating work for us
as browser vendors to
make your site just
get faster automatically.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
So if we can move on
to the next slide.
So it's not just on us.
It's also on developers
that work with us.
And so part of it
is better tooling
so that you can understand your
own performance really well.
So of course, DevTools
is incredibly powerful.
A new feature that you can try
out in Canary behind the flag
today is a feature
called Filmstrip.
So what it does, it shows
you-- you can see it up there
in that row of
images-- it shows what
pixels were on screen
at different parts
as you loaded the page.
And so you can see here
this random cwilso guy,
his blog is hitting about
eight seconds for the pixels
to be on screen, which
is way past the one
second that you want with RAIL.
And so now, of course,
you dig in with DevTools
and figure out what's going on.
ELISABETH MORANT: So
DevTools is really powerful
but you basically need a
PhD to understand all of it.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
It's so overwhelmingly
powerful sometimes.
So we're also
working on tools that
will make it so that
you can open up DevTools
and it will say, hey,
you're consistently
missing the A in RAIL.
Turns out that this third party
script, this analytic script,
is doing way too
much work on scroll.
Consider removing it.
And so making it much
easier for you to dive in
without having to get a PhD.
And of course, the
last one is just
holding ourselves
as web developers
to a higher standard.
So the I/O web app
is an amazing example
of a highly responsive, 60
frames per second web app.
Now, it wasn't easy to build but
it is getting easier and easier
every day.
And all of us,
every single time we
include a third party
script or resource
or we fetch out to another
third party domain,
we should ask ourselves,
is this worth it?
Is this going to make me go
past those goals in RAIL?
So there's only so much
time to cover performance.
The point is that we've
made a lot of big strides
and I think this is a
great framework for us
as a community.
ELISABETH MORANT: So the web
has a superpower of reach,
and now it's possible to have
60 frames per second, even
for the most
complex mobile apps,
but what the web is
missing is the ability
for users to build meaningful
relationships with the stuff
that they find to really engage.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
So I mean, speed
dating is great.
You meet a whole bunch of people
in a very short amount of time,
but what if you meet
that person and you
got a little bit of a spark?
You want to get to
know them a little bit.
ELISABETH MORANT: Exactly, and
native apps are great at this.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
I've got an idea.
Why don't we just
list all the things
native apps can do and
just copy that for the web?
ELISABETH MORANT: Well,
I wish it were that easy.
The problem is that
with every new API also
comes a whole new
set of risks, and we
want to maintain the
security guarantees
of the web, the ability
for users to jump to a link
and not worry that something's
going to happen to them.
So let's take, for example,
background sync, background
sync being the ability for an
app to fetch and send content
when the app is closed.
So if you're visiting
over 100 sites a month,
then you don't necessarily want
them all to arbitrarily start
syncing the background.
Just like let's say you
browse some embarrassing sites
at home, like some
celebrity gossip site.
I'm not going to call
what celebrity Alex is
obsessed with.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Guilty.
ELISABETH MORANT: And
then you go to work,
and in the meantime,
your phone lost battery.
You turn it on when you get
to work, and all of a sudden,
you start fetching embarrassing
content while you're
on your corporate network.
Well, we're trying to
save people like Alex
from an embarrassing visit
to the sys admin's office.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
I get that.
I see.
ELISABETH MORANT: And so
basically, if we bring back
the speed dating
metaphor, let's say
that you meet someone
for the first time
and you really feel that
spark and you think,
this could be the one.
Do you give them the
keys to your apartment,
introduce them to your
parents, bend down on one knee
and vow to spend the rest
of your life together?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yes.
ELISABETH MORANT: No.
Of course not.
Jeez, that could
be a serial killer.
So the idea is that you want
to build a relationship slowly.
The problem is that we can't
necessarily emulate or copy
the powerful model
of native apps
because native apps have a
store, they have ops teams,
and the web is open.
And so what we want
to do is enable
websites to progressively
ask permission
for powerful and
engaging features.
And the idea is
that users should
be able to indicate
when they want
to trust this site enough to
give them certain permissions.
Basically, if everyone got
access to your bank account
as soon as you met
them, you probably
wouldn't want to
leave your house.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So it's
more important for the reach
of the web than to have
all these capabilities
for every random site you go to.
ELISABETH MORANT: Exactly.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Got it.
ELISABETH MORANT:
And so the idea
is that with all these new
APIs come a set of risks,
and Chrome has
this responsibility
to make sure that people can
still browse the web securely.
Now, with this in
mind, we've already
brought a few exciting
APIs to the web
and we're going to talk
about two of them right now.
The first is Add to Homescreen.
So typing, especially
on a mobile,
is really hard, but mobile is
where people go to kill time.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So, I mean,
you go to the coffee shop
to meet your friend.
They aren't there yet.
You want to read something
interesting but not
too interesting because at
any point they might show up
and you have to put
your phone away.
ELISABETH MORANT: Exactly.
So you open up your
phone, you tap an icon,
and you fall into
some experience
that you're OK jumping
back out of again.
And so we already have
the ability for people
to add sites to
their home screen.
It's buried deep
in the settings,
but we found it had
surprisingly high usage.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So why don't we
just make that way more obvious
and make it really hard to miss?
ELISABETH MORANT:
Well, if people
are visiting 100
websites every month,
then probably every new
help form you go to,
you don't want to necessarily
add it to your home screen.
And so what we've done is we've
incorporated some really smart
heuristics and said
developers can use this API
and request to be added
to the home screen
as long as people have in
each with the app enough
that we've detected
that they actually want
that app on their home screen.
So take this as an example.
I really enjoy
reading Vice News,
and I read an article
earlier this week.
And this morning I
opened it up again,
And I found that I got this
prompt from Vice to add
the website to my home screen.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
That's awesome, but what
happens if you tap that
and you don't have connectivity?
ELISABETH MORANT:
Well, what you don't
want to see is the
dreaded offline dinosaur,
and so native apps actually
handle this case very well.
Even if an app depends
on connectivity to work,
they usually have some sort
of splash screen saying,
sorry, you can't use
this, but come back later,
something custom to the app.
And for that reason,
we've only enabled
Add to Homescreen
for those sites that
have a meaningful
offline experience.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Which
is a great point
that offline is an
incredibly important thing
for building engaging
experiences on mobile web.
So obviously, on
your mobile devices,
you're way more likely to
have a flaky connectivity
or no connectivity, like being
at a tech conference where
the Wi-Fi doesn't work
exactly as it should.
The problem is that
historically, we've only
had App Cache to handle this.
ELISABETH MORANT: So what's
the problem with App Cache?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: App Cache
wasn't exactly very popular.
So it was easy to get
started, which is great,
and it's declarative,
which is also great,
but it's kind of complex.
If you do anything
rather slightly complex,
you can't do the
things you want to do
and it quickly falls down.
It is unworkable in practice.
So what you need, of
course, is more control,
and Service Worker
brings you that control.
So let me tell you how it works.
The basic idea is
when you visit a site,
you can install
a Service Worker,
and that Service
Worker is basically
a script off to the side.
And now, when the
browser is going
to fetch a resource
from your domain,
instead of going
to the network, it
asks the Service Worker,
hey, what do you want to do?
And the Service Worker
can say, just do
what you would have done,
go to the network, please,
or it can say, please hand
back this thing from the cache,
or it can even say, create
a resource on the fly
and pass that.
ELISABETH MORANT:
So basically, it's
a client side proxy
written in JavaScript.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Exactly.
So this allows you
to build arbitrarily
complex offline experiences.
And when I say "arbitrarily,"
what I mean is you
can build something extremely
complex or extremely simple.
So the I/O web app
is a great example
of a complex offline web app.
It does very careful caching
so that even if you load it
when you're fully offline,
you get something meaningful,
but then when you're connected,
it will show you UI about, hey,
there's fresh content.
Tap here to see it.
Of course, a more likely
scenario or easier scenario
is just to aggressively
cache everything
you use so that your
thing works offline.
There's a great Gulp
plug-in called sw-precache
that makes it incredibly easy to
integrate into your workflows.
And of course, the simplest
possible thing you can do
is get rid of that darn
offline dinosaur for your thing
and basically say,
hey Service Worker,
if the user tries to fetch my
site and we're fully offline,
instead of showing
the offline dinosaur,
just show my own
little splash screen
that says, please connect to
the internet and try again.
That takes only a few
lines of JavaScript.
So Service Worker
is cool for offline,
but it has another
trick up its sleeve.
So a Service Worker, a single
one, can talk to multiple tabs
or it can talk to no tabs.
So it's the first place that
we as developers have a place
to write and run script even
when no tabs for my site
are open.
ELISABETH MORANT: That's bad.
People don't want any
random site executing
scripts in the background.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
Exactly, and that's
why Service Workers
are event driven.
So what happens is a networking
event happens, the browser goes
to the Service
Worker and says, hey,
I've got this network event.
Service worker handles
it and then it's done.
It's just sitting there not
doing anything because it
can't.
And so at that point, we
can freeze dry that thing,
put it off in storage.
ELISABETH MORANT: Right, until
the browser sends a new event
to wake it up.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Exactly.
So when a new event
comes in, we bring it
back into memory really
quickly, which takes,
I think, around 50 milliseconds
or so in practice in the wild,
and then it can go on its way.
So the cool thing is that
this isn't just related
to network events.
You can also imagine
other types of events
that would potentially
wake it up to do work.
ELISABETH MORANT: I see.
So the browser can
choose what type of event
it wants to send based on what
it thinks the user actually
wants.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Exactly.
So this is really powerful.
It enables an entirely
new class of functionality
that before wasn't even
possible to bring to the web.
ELISABETH MORANT: So one of
the new features only made
possible because of Service
Worker is push notifications.
Until now, only native
apps were able to send
push notifications,
but there are
cases where you would want push
without everything else that
comes with being an app.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
are these important?
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah.
This is extremely important.
Basically, notifications are
game changing for engagement.
More and more, people are
interacting with their phone,
opening up new apps
and experiences largely
because they got a
notification first,
and it's much less common that
people will open up their phone
and dumbly look
at their app grid
and decide what
they want to use.
Here's an example.
So the Guardian has
a native app and they
found that in the hours after a
breaking news event, up to 40%
of their article views came
from push notifications alone.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wow.
ELISABETH MORANT: It's huge.
And so to demonstrate
how important this is,
I'm going to jump into a demo.
So nine months ago, Oscars
season, I was at home
but I had to do a
lot of work so I
wasn't able to watch
the Academy Awards live.
This was a huge bummer for me,
so what I ended up doing was
I would jump between
my computer and then I
kept refreshing the Guardian
live blog to see who had won.
And what I would
do is I'd refresh
and I'd see what Reese
Witherspoon is wearing,
and then I'd click
on that and look
at some of her past filmography,
and then just get distracted
and jump back to my computer.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Basically,
getting nothing done.
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah.
Basically, I was not getting
anything done, or at least
I wasn't getting a
lot of work done.
But what if the Guardian
had push notifications?
What if I didn't have
to jump in and engage
and instead the Guardian told
me when there was information
that I actually wanted to know.
So suppose I open up the
live blog and I scroll down
and I see the ability
to follow the story.
So the Guardian
explains why I'd want
to opt in to
notifications, I want
to engage with this
particular piece of content,
so I hit Enable
Browser Notifications.
And at this point, Chrome
sends me the prompt,
and yes, I want
notifications, so I say Allow.
Great.
So, now confident that I'm
going to get notifications
about the content
I'm interested in,
I can just close Chrome
and get back to work.
So I'm working and I
see a notification.
I don't know if you can see it.
I haven't tested this out.
So I see a notification
on my watch
that says that sound
editing won some award.
Now, this is one of those lame
awards so I just swipe it away.
I don't care.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So you
got that on your watch?
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah.
I got it on my watch because
Chrome sends notifications
just like any other Android app
would, and in that same way,
I get notifications on
my phone just like I
do from my messaging apps.
So I wasn't interested in that
content, so I go back to work,
drinking coffee, eating donuts,
writing very important briefs.
Oh.
I see another notification.
And this one, of course,
"Birdman" won best picture.
I mean, clearly we all know
that the movie that should have
won the award was "The Grand--"
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Wait, wait.
ELISABETH MORANT: "The
Grand Budapest Hotel,"
which I'm sure everyone else in
the room agrees with me about.
So in order to
express my opinion,
maybe I'll dive into the live
blog, open up the website,
maybe leave a few very
tastefully written comments
about why this movie
should have won.
Anyway, but I won't
bore you with that now.
So the point is
push notifications
let you know information
when you want it.
Alex?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: What?
ELISABETH MORANT: I'm so sorry.
Can you just-- you know
how to wrap this up.
I just-- Imagine Dragons
tickets just went on sale.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
Are you kidding me?
We're in an I/O talk.
ELISABETH MORANT: I
know, but I told you
they're going to sell out
and I really love this band,
and I just-- it'll take
me, like, two seconds.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
Great.
I guess why don't we
go back to the slides?
So I think the point that
Elisabeth was going to make
is that push
notifications are great.
In some cases, the
notification is the content.
You get all you need
just by seeing it.
In some cases, you
want to dive in.
And in other cases,
it's information
that is so important to you that
you want it to interrupt you
at any time or place, including
when you're presenting in front
of hundreds of people at I/O.
ELISABETH MORANT:
I got the tickets.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Great.
So happy for you.
Hope it was worth it.
ELISABETH MORANT:
Anyway, the point
is that push notifications are
this new primary interaction
paradigm.
It's how people engage
with their apps.
And bringing push
notifications to the web
allows you get information
about what you care about
before you've decided
to necessarily commit
to everything else
that comes with an app.
So for example, I visit
Ticketmaster once every couple
of months, but I really
wanted notifications
about this particular
piece of content.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
So the obvious question
that we all have
is when can we use this?
Six months from now?
A year from now?
ELISABETH MORANT: Well, this
is shipped to all Chrome users
today, so anyone who visits
a site with this enabled
will be able to get push
notifications or the Add
to Homescreen prompt
and developers
can start adding this to
their site at any time.
And so the Guard--
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think
it's pretty cool, too.
ELISABETH MORANT:
Pretty cool, right?
So the Guardian
and Ticketmaster,
both of these engineering
teams built the prototypes
that you saw today,
and they're planning
on bringing push
notifications to their sites
live in the coming months.
And they're not the only ones.
We have a number
of early adopters
who are rolling out push
notifications within the coming
weeks.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So the
cool thing about this, too,
is this isn't just some
Chrome only feature.
We designed this very
collaboratively with Mozilla,
working in standards bodies.
And in fact, this is a
screenshot from Firefox
that I took a couple days
ago, Nightly Build with a flag
flipped that shows them
asking for permission
for push notifications.
So that will be coming
there at some point, too.
It's pretty exciting.
So Service Workers allows us to
bring all kinds of capabilities
to the web that before
really didn't make sense
or couldn't make sense.
And because we're designing
them with other browser vendors
and standards bodies,
it's something
that you can come to rely on.
It's kind of like the dawn of
a new era for the mobile web.
ELISABETH MORANT: OK.
We promised we were only
going to talk about today, not
the future.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: OK.
Well, the cool
thing about this is
you can start today
because these features are
great at progressive
enhancement.
So if you go to one of these
sites in a browser that doesn't
support push notifications,
well, you see the same site
that you would have
seen before, but if you
go to that site in a browser
that does support push
notifications, maybe they
add another button that says,
hey, I want to be notified
when this thing changes.
And then if I as
a user opt in, I
can have a really
high value thing
that's really important
to me even before it's
shipped in every
browser out there,
so I think that's
pretty exciting.
ELISABETH MORANT: So
we talked about a lot
of topics at a high
level today, but there
are a number of
DevBytes and box talks
that you can visit that will
go into a lot of these topics
more in depth.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So today, we
talked about three things.
ELISABETH MORANT: The
superpower of the web, reach.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: How performance
has made huge strides
on mobile web.
ELISABETH MORANT: And how
we're baking powerful new ways
for you to build relationships
with your users, many available
now and a lot more coming soon.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
the three of these
alone aren't that special.
It's the confluence
of these three things
that's really important.
ELISABETH MORANT: Well, you're
forgetting the most important
one.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's a good
point because these things
by themselves, they just make
it possible to do cool things,
but what happens
when you combine
that with this global community
of tinkerers and builders
and makers, well, that's when
something really awe inspiring
happens.
ELISABETH MORANT: We can't
wait to see what you build.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think if there
are any live questions,
we can take them here.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, fantastic talk.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The question is
about the Service Workers
which respond to events.
Does it involve events
like Ajax requests
or it's only when you don't have
a network which [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
basically, what happens
is you get a fetch event.
So in your Service
Worker you say,
Chrome, please notify me when
any content from my domain
is fetched, and then
you'll catch that event,
you'll pass in what the
request URL was, and you
can respond to it that way.
That happens even
when you're fully
connected because of course, you
might be on flaky connectivity,
and so you want to make sure
you can design your experience
with total control
over what happens
over networking to your site.
AUDIENCE: So you meant
content, like HTML,
or it includes Ajax requests?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Basically
almost every request that
goes to your site.
There's a few exceptions
for specific things.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're using things
like OAuth, which
automatically authenticates,
what's the design
pattern to get data?
Like, for example, if you
used Google+ authentication,
which directly logs
onto your page--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think
that's a great question
to go into in more depth
in the office hours,
but you have total
control over this.
It's pretty powerful.
AUDIENCE: I've got an
easy one for you, I hope.
The home screen.
You mentioned that you find
it interesting how many people
use the home screen.
I'm shocked at that.
Where can I see the numbers for
it, how many people actually
add stuff to the home screen?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
I don't know if we
have those numbers
to share today,
but it's one of those
things that even
despite being a buried
feature, I think
people find a lot of value in.
That's one of the
reasons that we
decided to bring this
feature to other websites
in a more proactive
way when we feel
pretty confident that the user
will be interested in that one.
AUDIENCE: Where can
I find those numbers?
Where do you find them from?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I'm sorry.
Those are numbers that
we have internally.
AUDIENCE: Oh, secret numbers.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
Yeah, secret numbers.
AUDIENCE: What's the
advantage of using a Service
Worker over something
like what we had at Angry
Birds two or three years ago.
At Google I/O two
or three years ago,
they were using offline
storage for Angry Birds.
What's the advantage of
using Service Worker?
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
So Service Worker
allows you to have very
fine grained control
over all aspects of what's
happening on the network,
so then you can use technologies
like Index DB and Explicit
Cache API to do stuff,
whereas before, you
were limited to a very high
level declarative approach.
If it worked for you, it
was great, but more likely
it didn't work for you.
It couldn't do exactly
what you wanted
to handle in this
particular case
and so it was basically useless.
So Service Worker,
the way to think of it
is-- are you familiar with
the Extensible Web Manifesto?
So that's a notion
that we should
be defining the lower
level primitives that
explain how the
web platform works,
so getting rid of
the high level magic
and giving developers access to
the low level primitives that
make that magic work.
So Service Worker
is like digging
down deep below App Cache
to figure out what was there
and how it worked and
expose that to developers.
Does that make sense?
Probably not, but OK.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question on the user
experience on the offline
sites that you showed me.
So let's say the user is
traveling inside a tunnel
and then there is
a network break.
So how do we notify the user
at this moment, you are online,
and then you go offline.
This experience that you're
having is the offline period,
and then the network
can come back again
and you can come online again.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's great.
So the cool thing
about Service Worker
is you have full control to
do what's right for your app.
So in particular--
for example, I
think the I/O app does this--
if you're on flaky connectivity,
it can say, I'm just going to
default and show everything
directly from the cache and
then fetch fresh resources.
And so what might happen is the
user is already looking at it.
Fresh content has come back.
You don't want to
go [MAKES NOISE]
and put the content
there because they'll
lose their train of thought.
But with Service Worker in some
of these demos, what people do
is they'll have a small
bit of UI that says,
"Fresh content is available
if you scroll up."
And that way, you don't
lose your way in the app.
But the point is,
of course, that you
have control to do what's
right for your app, which
is pretty exciting.
AUDIENCE: That's cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is in the
demo that you showed.
I get a notification
from the Guardian app
and you go to the home screen
of the Guardian app icon,
and then you click, and then
you open, and then you read.
Is it possible that from the
notification directly, I can--
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah.
That was just a bug in the demo.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
So what happens is
when you tap on
the notification,
your Service Worker
receives an event
that says the
notification was clicked.
At that point, you can
say, OK, do nothing,
or you can say, focus a
tab that existed before
or open a new tab.
ELISABETH MORANT: Yeah.
So I was supposed to
click on the notification
and jump directly to the content
that it was notifying me about.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Very similar
question, but rather
than tapping on a
notification, what if you
get an email with a link?
Is there any kind of
association that would open up
that installed web app?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I don't know the
particulars of exactly how it
works, but if you
are an installed web
app with a manifest, there
will be some cases that
don't necessarily fit exactly
perfectly into the intent
system of Android, but
we're working on those.
I don't have all the information
for you in depth on that,
though.
You should take it
to office hours.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: One question.
AUDIENCE: Are the
notification preferences
synced across a user's
account or is it per device?
ELISABETH MORANT:
It's per device.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And
the reason for that
is the context that you opt
in is very device specific.
So I might be interested
in seeing celebrity gossip
on my personal-- because
I have a thing for that,
apparently-- on my
personal machine,
but I don't care
about it enough to be
notified when I'm on the go.
And so exactly where
the right user context
depends on the device you're
in, and so it's not synced.
AUDIENCE: And is the
notification preference
per domain or per
specific website?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's
per domain, basically.
And so the idea is you want
to make sure as a site author
that you use it
very respectfully.
So one thing we
didn't show in this
is the notifications
that show up
have a very obvious
Site Settings button
and if a user taps on that,
they're taken directly
into Chrome Settings
for that domain, where
it's a couple more taps
to revoke permissions
for that domain.
And so as a site
author, you want
to make sure that you explain
to users what you're going to do
and that you respect their
attention because it's
very, very easy for
them-- of course,
they're in control-- to
revoke permission very easily
if you abuse it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Sure.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]